Mark: Is this... Undertale?
Tyler: Boop.. boop
*Undertale's opening title music plays in the background*
Mark: Ah, yes...... i-i-it is.
Tyler: *confused noises*
Mark: Hideledeledele-- if anyone's watching, we're not ready yet; everybody, just hold on to your horses, we'll be roight with you.
Mark: Hold on to your unicorns. *stupid grin*
*Mark & Tyler giggling*
Mark: Alright, anyway, we-we're still getting things ready, we were not...
Uh, we were very busy!
Today. We've been very busy for a while.
Tyler: Well, to be honest.
Tyler: I mean... th-the carpet changed.
Tyler: I can't see it, but...
Mark: Yay! ...Yeah, we finally pulled up all the plastic.
Mark: When they installed it, they-- we still had like construction people coming in and out of our building.
Mark: Uh, so... they put down this plastic so they wouldn't get their muddy work boots all over it-- And we finally pulled it up!
Mark: It's so nice except for the stains.(Laughs)
Tyler: Where the carpet-or the covering went.
Mark: Yeah, the like, plastic ripped- This doesn't matter to any of you guys,
Tyler: *laughs*
Mark: But it's important to us, it's our life, so we need to talk about it.
Mark: A hole ripped in the plastic, so they're just like....
Mark: *imitates noise*
Mark: Like, like stains of dark brown that are just like, shit stains
*Tyler laughing*
Tyler: They're not brown, they're like gray.
Mark: They're pretty brown, man.
Tyler: Well and then there's some Chica h-hair around, 'cause she gets soo excited when we bring her to the office.
Mark: Oh my god, she goes nuts.
Mark: I don't ta- I don't get her out of the house enough.
Mark: Like, I need to take her for more regular walks, 'cause I'm not good about that.
Mark: I'm a bad dog-daddy.
Mark: Everyone can- say I'm a bad dog-daddy.
Mark: I mean, I play with her- I play the- play the- play the crap out of her -uh- everyday,
Mark: but just I- I- I'm not a good-
*Tyler staring*
Mark: Don't look at me like that!
Tyler: "play the crap out of her" I just pictured...*laughs*
Mark: I play the- I pick her up like a flute and I play the crap out of Chica
right up to her butt, *imitates saxophone* and I play the crap out of her
Mark: Don't question me! I know what I'm doing.
Mark: Alright, so we're still uh...
Mark: Oh yeah, the game's up...
Tyler: Uhhh
Mark: ...and you guys should be here, BUT, before that, WE, are gonna.... oh what the-
Tyler: We're gonna talk about the -uh- the new videos
Mark: Oh yeah! Yeah, absolutely! Um, we'll- we- we- uh- We've been doing something new.
Mark: Why does it say offline? Oh that's- that's a different- that's a different stream
Mark: I was like, "Are we offline?! No? Oh, okay, alright"
Tyler: Oh, what
Mark: so we should be - yeah
Yes?
Tyler: you have like a minute to something..
Mark: the heck was that?
someone breaking in?
no
Tyler: our-
*both laugh*
Mark: our ever-growing pile of trash
keeps collapsing in on itself
it's so- *laughs*
Tyler: from all the stuff we've got for the office
*Tyler laughs*
Mark: It's so heavy, every box we've ever opened is like,
piling in on itself
*both laugh*
Mark: cuz we're too lazy - the dumpster's so far away I don't wanna move it all
*while laughing* so we kinda just let it pile up like a bohemian
Tyler: we- we're gonna go buy a wheelbarrow
Mark: ..I don't wanna buy a wheelbarrow..*Tyler laughs*..you'll be my wheelbarrow
Tyler: *stumbling over words*
*both laugh*
Mark: that was a dirty joke
oh man...
Tyler: we used to do..
"wheelbarrow" races in wrestling
Mark: we used to do wheelbarrow every evening
Tyler: w..?
Mark: *laughing* when we were having gratuitous amounts of sex
Tyler: I wa- *laughs*
Mark: is what he's getting at
yes, it's true
Tyler: oohh jeez
Mark: wrestling was a fun time
Alright, so anyway
What were we tal- we were talking about something
Tyler: we were talking about the new videos
Mark: yes!
Tyler: the format that we've gotten so excited about
Mark: yess!
Mark: my god, it has been the most fun I've ever had making videos since I started doing YouTube, in fact
like it's..it- it's been that big of a deal
for us, uh, i- time wise, it's been crazy
but man, I- I am so happy
uh...to have been able to get out and do those things
it's just...
d- I've been gushing about it for like the past few hou- like, days straight
Tyler: *laughs* I- you were like..hours. No, it's been days
Mark: hours, days - whatever it is
uh..
*overlapped confused mumbled words*
Tyler: dreams about editing them
Mark: yeah, oh my god
*Tyler laughs*
Mark: legitimately, it was like a full-on-
y- you- I don't know how to pronounce it but...
gero...ge...jiro...
Jiro Dreams of Sushi!
y'know, th- that one
*still trying to say it* euro. Euro dreams of sushi
Tyler: I think it's...
Mark: eero? I dunno
Tyler: I think it's eero
Mark: someone...someone will correct me in a sassy way, I know...
(It's Jiro)
..very soon, but..
(I already did)
I- it- I- it was full-on that movie because I was legitimately last night dreaming
about the last video that we did -
*trying again to pronounce words*
Leecht- Lichtspeer
apparently it's not "Leechtspeer", it's "Lichtspeer"
Tyler: Lichtspeer
Mark: *overly enunciating* Lichtspeer
It's Lichtspeer which means "light spear" in....German..?
(no)
(it's Dutch)
...probably...
*both laugh*
Mark: but uh, yeah, I was dreaming about that last night, and I- I woke up super early
an- and if you guys remember me talking about..like...
my first time doing youtube, and my first time doing all this stuff, like I would....
get up at...ungodly hours of the morning
and then stay up waay too late just because I was so excited about making videos
and that is how this past week has been
..like..
it's..
Tyler: we haven't gone to bed until like...midnight or later
Mark: yeah, midnight or later - and that might se- not seem like much to you guys but
we've been getting up at 7am every day as well
so uh...
Tyler: well, technically we're waking up at 6, 6:30
Mark: that is true, yeah
*Tyler laughs*
Mark: and this- this morning, I didn't even need to, but I got up at 6:30
uh..
but it's- it's been like this...
I always talk about this fire and passion that burns in your heart for what you wanna do
and like-
I didn't even realize that it had gone out a bit for me,
and that's a sad thing to say, but it's like kinda true
uh, because I- I've just been doing let's plays so long, and I've been like, keeping it going and interesting
with like, challenge videos and sketches every once in a while, but like...
this just hit such a profound target in me
and the response is AMAZING!!
Tyler: oh my god...
Mark: like, my god!
I- I'm so like, ecstatic with everything
because this all started with Disco Discomfort, okay
I- we'll get to Undertale real soon, but I, like..
I will explode if I can't talk about this
*Tyler laughs*
Mark: um..
It all started with Disco Discomfort because - the funny story about that is that let's play, I recorded that like
three weeks ago
Tyler: forever ago
Mark: forEVER ago
Mark: like, three weeks..
Tyler: which gave me plenty of time to order the outfits
*glitchy stream whoops*
Mark: yeah, the- everyone was like "where'd you get the outfits?!"
It's like...they've been sitting in my living room for like three weeks straight..I dunno, I dunno what to do
(nothing's wrong with the video, glitchy stream)
but uh, so we uh..
I- I recorded that three weeks ago and when I walked out of the recording room, I went over to Tyler
and I was just like...I have a really cool idea
..what if we go out..
in public and find fans and dance with them?
and that was literally the only idea
that was it!
Tyler: and then we built off of it
Mark: yeah!
Tyler: as the weeks progressed slowly
and when Ethan came out
Mark: yeah
Tyler: he's..over there..editing right now
Mark: yeh
Tyler: um...and checking on the stream
how- eh- we sound good?
Ethan: mhm
Tyler: we're doing good? Okay
Um.
When Ethan came out here we were able to refine more ideas and be able to do so much more
Mark: yeah
Tyler: and we're so excited for so many other ideas that we have coming up
Tyler: it's just...
Mark: it's just- i- it's been a bit of a time crunch this week - and we KNOW, like, we're aware that videos have been sparse - like, we KNOW that...
*Tyler laughs*
Mark: we're fully aware of it, but
just - uh - because we did not- we went into this week without planning ahead
like every day - well, what happened is I recorded all the let's play stuff at the beginning of this week
and then we came up with ideas, but we have other things that we're doing
we're like working out regularly now, we're going rock climbing like twice a week, we're working out three times a week
we got-
Tyler: we're trying to still get Ethan set up
Mark: Ethan!
yeah, Ethan is new to LA so we're trying to get him in here without like, burdening him with too much work
and he's been such a great help, uh
here...uh..
*to Ethan* don't get an ego, y- j- shut up
Tyler: don't get sappy over there
Mark: get back to work there!
*both laugh*
Mark: so anyway
uh, yeah, it's been- it's been a busy week, this week in particular
but that doesn't mean that we haven't been unbelievably excited to be doing these videos,
and I'm just like tickled to death at the response of it
when - I-I-I- I can't remember who said it..but someone said that these videos were like...
it- a lot of people said that these videos were like...
reminded them of the reason they subscribed to my channel,
and that like - I was like...oh.. oh n...oh noo....oh, my heart oh jeez
I was like...so so taken aback
Tyler: the first one we made was like
when we were editing it, Mark just got into it and got extremely excited, like this is what he always dreamed of
Mark: Yeah...
Mark: I- I- it was like, it was the moment where I realized that I could combine everything that I've learned about YouTube videos into one video
and make it something cohesive and interesting and entertaining
and like...its- I can't gush about it enough - and I KNOW!
I know.. I- I- I...
*Tyler laughs*
I get it, yeah, I know fully well that, like...*giggles* It's just...it's- it's- it's new, and like
It's, to some people it's like *makes random rambling sounds* "where are the regular videos?" like,
I- we- we know, it's been a very busy week, and doing  one video a day is like the only thing we could've possibly done
to keep up with it and still do this new thing and explore this territory so I will say we are learning
we're learning about this
Tyler: and we're trying to refine the process to make it go quicker
Mark: yeah, exactly
so we're getting on that, I will stop gushing about it and we can get to the game right about now
but, it's just *to Tyler* scooch that way, just a scooch
Tyler: scooch, scooch
Mark: just a hair
Tyler: I scooched it
Mark: yeah, it is- it is just...I dunno, man...awesome, it's just so exciting
like, I c- I can't overstate my satisfaction about what we're doing
sO
I will stop talking *laughs*
Tyler: without further adieu...
Mark: without further adieu, welcome back to Undertale
uh, part five
what did we just leave off with?
Tyler: uh, the robo-
Mark: oh, *whining to Tyler* will you grab my water bottle?
*weird Tyler noises*
both: ETHAN!!
*Tyler laughs*
Mark: m-my water..*laughs*
Tyler: waateer, I need mine!
Mark: it's are so hard, it's so far away..
Tyler: grab mine! Hurry up...
Mark: chop chop!
Tyler: ooohh thank you so much
Mark: people're waiting for Undertale
Tyler: thank you
Mark: my goodness, we've been playing for 413 minutes
huh
anyway
Mark: okay. Boop!
Tyler: did we ever leave it - I dunno
Mark: did we what?
Tyler: I don't think never left it open. Soo we left off...when you defeated yourself
Mark: defeated my...oh yeah! cuz Mettaton is exactly me
Tyler: the robo-man!
Mark: so we're gonna be doing a chill stream - we've been looking forward to the stream all week just because
we've been wanting to talk about everything that we've been doing this whole time and Undertale is actually a pretty good game to do that over
and also I want to do streams more, so like - it- it- in the end, I- I- I was saying to Tyler just a little bit ago that I miss the old style of Let's Plays
and stuff like that where - where it was less about like fancy editing, and it was less about like stupid jokes, and whatnot
and it was more about the game and that's weird of me to say, considering we've been making these videos with all this editing and weird stuff
but at the same time it's like it - because I've been reminiscing about everything that we have been doing it's just been like bringing back all these old feelings of like-
Tyler: back when you first started
Mark: yeah! exactly
like back when I first was doing YouTube in fact, when I first just uh, playing Let's Plays and-
ooohh...
Tyler: oh..
Mark: and it, it was...
Tyler: pink..carpet
Mark: and it was....
it was..is that pink or is that mauve?
(it's actually more of a plum)
I still don't know what mauve is
I remember mauve from Hey Arnold, "the mauve avenger"
who is that?
Mark: *gasp*
Tyler: o-
Mark: iz spider?
*Tyler excited noise*
[Muffet, as played by Mark]: Welcome to our parlor, dearie~
[Muffet/Mark]: Interested in some spider pastries?
Mark: oohhhh
[Muffet/Mark]: all proceeds go to real spiders~
Mark: *gasp*
Tyler: if we don't buy from her, is she gonna eat us?
Mark: ...looks like some sort of powerful bracelet..? Wait- it's a croissant
oh. Well then
I have no idea
It's a spider donut. It looks more...rubbery than usual
huh
[Muffet/Mark]: spider bake sale, all proceeds go to real spiders
Mark: do we still have the spider stuff?
Tyler: I don't know...I th..I think we- we ate it
Mark: do we need it?
Mark: no, we didn't eat it, that would've been to important to eat - we ate the candy, but not the spider stuff
Mark: do I need to bring...
Tyler: it's in the booox
Mark: what if I go get it?
Tyler: yeah
Mark: is that gonna do anything to this?
I have no idea, this is - this is like us just exploring here
Mark: ...please select a location - where was our last-?
Tyler: there was a..
Tyler: uuhh...
Mark: uuhh...
Tyler: wait, didn't we get the dimensional box?
Mark: YOU'RE RIGHT WE GOT A BOX ON OUR PHHOOOOONE good call, good call
(pun not intended?)
dimensional box A...
Mark: ahhh....
Tyler: spider cider spider donut!
Mark: spider cider spider donut, we do have the things
both: okay
Mark: alrighty then
let's see if this does absolutely anything
..what if we have to eat it in front of them? And she's like NO! OUR BABIES! You ate all of our spider babies! NOOO!
Tyler: all the eggs!
Mark: all the eggs! How could you??
Tyler: the silk fill- silk?
*gibberish*
Mark, mumbling: Let's see...
Mark: *mubling* all proceeds go to real spiders
Mark: Well, that did nothing
Tyler: I think maybe you can only buy 'em
Tyler: oh, wait-
Mark: o- no, that was just...
Tyler: you have to- that's where you buy 'em, yeah
Mark: nine-
both: wwhhhaaaaatt??
Mark: wa??
Tyler: I think she's...
she's...
she's in it for herself
Mark: ah..
Tyler: I don't like her
[Mark as new character]: I ended up buying a donut
[Mark as character]: I...I...I didn't want to, but that girl...
[Mark as character]: even though I told her no, she...
[Mark as character]: kept staring at me in this creepy way and licking her lips
Tyler: I told you if you didn't buy anything she'd eat you!
and it's saying that just now, it's scared to be eaten
[Mark as character]: now i'm outta cash!
Mark: well, uh...
*laughing* if I try to leave will it not let me?
Tyler: let's try
let's do it
Mark: a-alrighty then
oh
Tyler: okay..
Mark: well there's gotta be something to this then, it can't just be...nine thousand gold for donuts
there's gotta be something here
Tyler: I don't wanna eat it....
Mark: ugh
Tyler: ugh
Tyler: w- and we don't need to heal...
'cause we're full health, so...
both: uugghh
Tyler: put it back in the box for now
Mark: alright fine
Mark: ooh maybe if I call Papyrus he'll be able to tell us what to do
Tyler: ooh that's a good idea
Mark: I know, I- I'm full of good ideas
you have no idea how many good i...
wait, check out the webs to make a purchase...okay...
hey
[Mark as Papyrus]: It might sound weird that spiders need donations, but think about it!
[Papyrus/Mark]: they have eight feet. That's four pairs of shoes. A spider wearing four pairs of pink booties
[Papyrus/Mark]: meditate on this image
Mark: medi- meditate. That did nothing for us
Mark: maybe there's absolutely no reason to do that
Tyler: yeah, maybe we should just go
Tyler: we should just go
Mark: okie dokie then
Tyler: before she kills us
Mark: ring
oh
[Tyler as Alphys]: hii, Alphys here!
*Mark laughs*
Mark: that is not...it was like a very timid, y'know
Tyler: I can't remember
[Alphys/Tyler]: hhhiii-
Tyler, breaking character: no
Mark: you did the same exact thing
Tyler: I know
Mark, mimicking Alphys/Tyler: hhiii
[Alphys/Tyler]: hhi, Al-phys heeere!
Mark: that is not at all what it was. You are a fool
Tyler: I am a fool. I don't remember how to do it
Mark: aah, it's okay
Tyler: we've been so busy doing other things...
[Mark as Alphys]: *quietly* hi, Alphys here
[Alphys/Mark]: this room is like the room we saw before
*Tyler quietly replicates how Mark is saying it*
[Alphys by Tyler again]: there are two puzzles to the north and south
Mark: there you go!
[Alphys/Tyler]: you'll...have to solve them both to proceed
Mark: *whispering* a little louder
*Tyler clears his throat*
[Alphys/Tyler]: a- also, I'd like to say....
[Alphys/Tyler]: I- I don't really.. like giving away puzzle solutions
[Alphys/Tyler]: bu- but if you need help.. just call me.. okay?
[Alphys/Tyler]: actually, wait - I have an idea!
[Alphys/Tyler]: let's be friends on UnderNet!
Mark: nooo
[Alphys/Tyler]: th- then you can just ping me when you n- need help!
Mark: noooo *sighs*
[Alphys/Tyler]: wait...we're already friends...aren't we..?
Mark: yes
[Alphys/Tyler]: I signed you up, didn't I?
*weird Mark noises*
[Alphys/Tyler]: you've been reading my posts th-the whole time...
*louder Mark noise*
[Alphys/Tyler]: well - I hope - you agree with me -
...
both: about Mew Mew 2
Mark: do you still not have your glasses?
(dang it Tyler)
Tyler: fuck
Mark: dang it, man!
Tyler: ...oh I just said fuck on a livestream - OOOHHH!
Mark: stop!
*both laugh*
Mark: I mean go ahead, I don't- I don't fuckin care
anyway. So
boink,
boink
I'm bad-ass
look at me
Tyler: *jams out to a "du du du du" that he's making up*
Mark: ..I'm the best...I don't know where I'm going...
Tyler: du du du du du - you screwed it up - du du du du
Mark: ...probably this way...how do you know?
Tyler: go- you should've went up there
Mark: you don't- you don't know that
Tyler: g- go back and go up
Tyler: no- ep- eh-
Mark: I couldn't go up
Tyler: go down...
go right...
Mark: go right...
Tyler: go up
Mark: up...up...ah, okay
Tyler:..go up...left...up
Mark: I had it, you didn't let me have it, I had that
Tyler: you did have it
Mark: aahh crap
Tyler: oohhhh
Mark: oh, no it's yan- IT'S T-SUNDERPLANE!
Tyler: t-sundeerrplaane!
Mark: ....what?
Tyler: i don't know
Mark: *really overemphasizing his wrong pronunciation*  t-suunderplane
it's Japanese pronunciation is tu-suun-de-re
(no it's not)
Tyler: t-sun-de-re...plane
Mark: how offensive are you? That's not at all the Japanese pronunciation of it!
it's suun-dere
(there ya go)
Tyler: tsundereplane
Mark: something like that, I have no idea
Tyler: I dunno
Mark: alright, whatever
what are we supposed to do?
oh we were supposed to raise the temperature
encourage and then dodge
i'm not gonna be able to dodge this crap
Tyler: why don't you go at the saaaame-
Mark: TOO LATE! (damn it mark)
Tyler: -plan fiirrrrssst (that's not how you do words)
Mark: you're too late
(Mark making sounds so he can dodge better)
oohhhhh myyyyyy goodness!
Mark: ok
Tyler: niicce
Mark: alright so is he good, to spare?
Pirate Tyler: "yarrr" alright
Mark: thank God
(unintelligible tsundere noises)
Mark: baka! b-baka! (idiot! i-idiot!)
Tyler: oh, this is- the plane is the one that..
Mark: ah!
Tyler: t- (tyler just can't do words today)
Mark: I have to get close to it,
Mark: but not- not- not too close, that's right
Tyler: riiiiggghhhttttt
Mark: let's see, "approach"
( ͡͡ ° ͜ ʖ ͡ °)﻿
Tyler: y-you- it's-it's the one that-
Mark: ugh
Tyler: -likes you, but doesn't like you
Mark: ooh
Mark: ow
Mark: boop be de boop ba do! ok..
Mark: ha ba do!
Tyler: that is very- niccee
Mark: i should stab them..
(moment of realization)
Mark: why is a plane.. here on this hot air?
this makes absolutely no sense!
*markimoo noises* how- I-Is this a full plane?
And why is a monster a plane *random hand gestures*
(I don't know markimoo... just because..?)
What does that say about the technology of the period? *Touches facial hair*
Where the humans come from?
Tyler: Hmmmmm...
Mark: Its a full plane. Right?
And we can assume that everything in this game is not an inside joke.
And everything must be canon, right? (WRONG!!!)
It's a plane and it can't just make up what a plane is
It has to know, right?
They have cellphones Tyler: Right.
Tyler: so are our airplanes living monsters?
Mark: NO!
Tyler: That's not what you were thinking? Mark: Not, not, not at all
Mark: okay so
Tyler: Oh it's the alien thing!
Mark: I only have one shot at this.
okay.
alright
Mark: this is gon-
Tyler: nonononono go back
Tyler: ohhh you already screwed up. :(
Mark: No I didn't. You don't know anything about me screwing up.
Mark: Only I know things about me screwing up.
*rad ass techno opera music*
Mark: *whispering* damnit
Mark: Dag nabit.
'kay
Mark: Hang on.
Wait.
Tyler: Well you have two shots, right?
Mark: No, I have one.
Mark: This one only has one shot.
Mark: So there must be...
Tyler: Here, go down-
Mark: Go down?
Tyler: Yup.
Tyler: Now go over.
Tyler: Now up.
(you go Tyler woohoo)
*INTENSE PUZZLE SOLVING*
Tyler: I think we might need to restart-
Mark: nah nah nah nah
Mark: nah nah, oh ye of little faith.
Mark: O-Oh ye- wait
Mark: Oh ye of lit. tle. faith,
Mark: HAAAA
Tyler: niiiiiicccceeee
Mark: See, you have no faith in me!
SKIDOOSH
Mark: As my favorite movie says,
SKADOOSH
Mark: Stay outta my swamp, skadoosh.
*disapproving tyler look*
Mark: Ogres are like onions, skadoosh!
Mark: Anyway.
Tyler: Skadoosh?
Mark: Skadoosh, woo
Tyler: Skahdouche
Mark: My fave Mettaton Moment- you be the other guy-
Diamond Face Mark: My fave Mettaton moment
Right when everything is the baddest he poses dramatically
like when he's on a cooking show,
and the eggs don't turn out riiighhht.
Diamond Face Tyler: My fav Mettaton Moment
is when he beats up the heel-turnin' villans.
Even if it's during what's supposed to be a quiz show.
Mark: wow
Mark: Why did they appear??
Tyler: Idk
Mark: That's the question like- characters appear
Mark: like so frequently I honestly have no idea
Mark: Like who they are- I gotta go the longer way around-
*tyler noise*
Mark: boopdedip boopbedip boopbedip BOO
Tyler: Noice
Mark: Thanks man
Tyler: NOICE...woop!
Mark: I try real hard to do the best that I can.
Mark: oooooh there's two puzzles probably one at the bottom then...
Mark: habooski
*skidooshing*
Mark: Like my favorite, uh, my favorite, fa-favorite
Mark: 3D Anime (is that a thing omg)
Mark: I'm makin' waffles! Skidddouchhe
Mark: u kno wha movie im talkin bout
Tyler: yeah...yeah..mhm
Mark: Land Before Time...B)
Tyler: *what the fuck, mark?*
Mark: *lmao im funny af*
(AHAHAH AH AHHHHH)
Tyler: There's a movie- are you naming the character?
Mark: No I was not, aw sh- aw come on.
Tyler: Oh those are the ones you have to stay moving through.
Mark: I got I got I got I got
Mark: shreked on that- what?
Tyler: no the orange ones you have to stay
Mark: what I thought-
Tyler: No, blue is- blue is sit still for that-
Mark: I did!
Mark: I did sit through it, it just blasted me anyway!
Tyler: well shi- hayyyyy
Mark: o
Tyler Alphys: This doesn't have anything to do with guiding you, but-
Tyler: Uhh, hey, would you want to watch a human TV show together?
Mark: How do they get human TV shows??
Mark: How do they get-
Tyler: an antenna drilled out of the cave.
Mark:Oh
Tyler: It's called, um, Mew Mew Kissy Cutie
MArk: It's called "Who's Line is it Anyway"
Mark: uhh
Mark and Tyler: I don't wanna watch Mew Mew Kissy Cutie
Mark: Sorry about this, no i don't wanna
Tyler: um, well, that's okay.
Mark: aw. Alphaplier is dead. :(
Tyler: Just thought I'd... ask...
Mark: Just thought I'D. ASK!
Tyler: But i THINK YOU'D REALLY LIKE IT
Tyler: If you gave it a CHANCE!
Mark: I don't know bout that..
Mark: Mew Mew Kissy Cutie
Mark: oh boi
Mark: Do I have one shot at this? One shot.
Mark: Alright. You ready for-
Mark: The ultimate-
Tyler: Oh you had it.
Mark: Did I-
Tyler: You just had it.
Mark: no
Tyler: Yes. Go down.
Mark: down..
Tyler: no no, go up.
Tyler: Down, left, right.
MArk: aaaAAAhhhh, this is the reason why I keep you around.
Mark: This guy right here.
Mark: Good job, that guy.
Mark: You're that guy...You're that guy
Tyler: I'm that guy.
Mark: WEE.. oh hello.
Mark: You stop to smell the flowers.
Mark: whhhhaaaaaaatt?
Mark: whhhhhhhaaaaat?
Mark: *whispers* whaaaaaaat?
Tyler: *whispers* what're they tryna say?
Mark: idk but they're yellow.
Tyler: They are yellow.
Mark: MM MMM MM MM
MArk: MM MM
Tyler: We don't like them. We don't like dem yellow flowers.
Mark: *derp noises*
Both: HERP
Mark: whaddarya tryna say?
Tyler: idk
Mark: You racist piece of crap.
Tyler: Why? okay. Apparently.
Mark: YAY
Mark: What'd we get? We opened the doors.
Tyler: The two green keys!
Mark: green keys?
Tyler: yeah they were green
Mark: oh ok
Tyler: *weird noises*
Mark: The smell of cobwebs fills the air.
Mark: You're filled with determination.
Mark: Oh- the oh- SPIDER ENTRANCE
MArk: We need the spider donut here.
Tyler: yeahh
Mark: okay so if I were to, say,
o nope
Mark: the signal is- woah what did that say?
Mark:...clogged with cobwebs.
Tyler: Oh, jeez.
Mark: So....It's alot of spidery stuff
Mark: so i'm gonna assumer
Tyler: lets get the spider cider and spider donut
Mark: Why do I need this- what is that?
Tyler: Hot Dog..?
Tyler: Let's put it in the box
Mark: Wait I'm gonna see what it is first.
Mark: Item...the heck is this?
MArk: The meat is made of something called water susage
Tyler: O yeah didn't we buy it from that one dude?
Mark: Or was this the one Sans gave us?
Tyler: It might've been the one Sans gave us.
Mark: I have no idea but we need to empty our
Mark: our stuff here a bit.
Mark: instant noodles...old tutut... we don't need the old tutu anymore.
Tyler: Hot Dog can go.
Mark: Maybe we need that.
Mark: I don't know what we need it-
Tyler: What'd the instant noodles for?
Mark: It's prolly just food, right?
Mark:... comes with everything you need for a quick meal.
Mark: Yeah, so it sounds like
Tyler: Oh so just put that away.
Mark: Well I'm gonna keep it in case I need to eat it because I don't really wanna eat any of this other stuff.
Tyler: Okay.
Mark: But we're gonna find out..
Mark: oooh spiders
Mark: why are going into this WUh
Mark: wondered what happened, wUH
Mark: U THINK, U THINK?
Tyler: What would happen if you stepped on it?
Mark: O JEEZ
Mark: OH JEEZ
Mark: O jeez, I shteppted on it.
Mark: Oh I stepped on it on the spider *hehehehe*
Mark: Uh oh
Tyler: OH
Mark: Uh oh.
Mark: Did you hear what they just said?
Mark: no
Mark: O jeez
Mark: O jeez oh gush
Muffet: ahuhuhuhu
Mark: They said a human wearing a striped shirt will come through.
Mark: okay
Mark: that sounds like me- oh jeez scoob
Muffet: ahuhuhuhu
MArk: I heard that they hate spiders.
????
Tyler: *whispers* that's why,
Mark: We're gonna eat spiders in front of them!
Tyler: Ohh noo
Mark: Get them to REALLY hate us, no we're not gonna do that.
*weird Mark noise*
Mark: I heard that they love to stomp on them.
Tyler: Oh,we're moving so slow.
Mark: Yep.
Mark: I heard that they like to tear their legs off-
Well that's not true at all.
Mark and Tyler: HHNNNNGGG
Mark: HUUUUHRHR
Mark: GEH
Tyler: OOOOH
Mark: I heard,
Mark: Oh hey- *GASP*
Mark: Hello, is that?
Mark: That they're- OOOOOOOOOOOOHHHHHH
Tyler: yeeeeaaaaaahhhhh
Mark: *tisk tisk-ing*
Tyler: We were good..!
Mark: They're awfully stingy with their money!
Mark: ahuhuhuhuhhuh
Tyler: I told you she was evil.
Mark: Yeah well I mean it's obvious
a horrible evil spider lady.
Mark: You think your taste is too refined
Mark: for our pastries, don't you dearie?
Mark: ahuhuhu
Mark: I disagree with that notion.
Mark: I think your taste...
Mark: ..is exactly what this next batch needs!
Mark: But I have...I have!
*SPIDER DANCE MY JAM*
Mark: I have a spider doNUT!
Tyler: Maybe we have- Muffet, woo
Mark: Muffet?
Mark: I've never even heard of this person.
Mark: blolboblob
Tyler: OH
Tyler: Little Miss Muffet who sat on her tuffet,
Tyler: eating her curds and whey.
Mark: Uh huh.
Tyler: Along came a spider who sat down beside her
Tyler: who scared Miss Muffet away!
Mark: DADADHDHADHADHADHA!
Mark: I remembered it too, just like you did!
Mark: I said the exact same words.
Mark: Anyway,
Mark: Well what do we do about the spider cider?
Mark: Dang it! Ah, that's not what I-
Tyler: I didn't-
Mark: Where did yo- OOOOOOOOOOH
Mark: Where did you get that?
Mark: Did you steal it?
Mark: Oh, my pet,
Mark: It's time to show them what we do with thieves!
Mark: Huh? A telegram from th- *GASP*
Tyler: yEAH!!!!
Mark and Tyler: WOOOOOO!!
Tyler: We did good!
Mark: I didn't even get to experience this battle.
Mark: They're saying that they saw you and
Mark: you were really passionate about spiders?
Mark: Oh my!
Mark: This has all been a big misunderstandin-
Mark: Well I didn't even get to experience the brunt of this battle!
Mark: I didn't even get to experience any of the sassy dialogue!
Mark: I didn't get to eat- be eaten by a spider.
Mark: Which was always my dream,
Mark: Tyler, what's the one thing- you've known me for years now,
Mark: What's one thing I've always said?
Mark: About what I want in life.
Tyler.exe is processing...
Tyler: ..to have red hair?
Mark: Wha- did-
Mark: YES
Mark: ..but also-
Tyler: ahahahahahhaahhahahahaahahaha
Mark: to be eaten by a spider!
Mark: I've been saying it since I was a child.
Tyler: Well I mean it's still better than Wade (what isn't?)
so when he dies he wants to be eaten by us.
*flabbergasted Mark*
Tyler: Did you not know this?! He wants to be a soup!
Mark: wh- hahahah at?
Tyler: He wants to be a soup!
Tyler: He wants his ashes to be put in a soup.
Mark: W h a t?!!!!!
Tyler: Sorry Wade, I ruined your secret!
Mark: Was it a secret??
Tyler: It wasn't! I don't think..
Mark: Not anymore!
Mark: Ohh boi.
Mark: WOW heheh
Tyler: You've never heard that?
Mark: I have never heard that in my LIFE.
Tyler: He talks about it all the time!
Mark: Never. Maybe he has, but maybe I blocked it out.
Mark: Alright.
Tyler: Don't like his recipe
Mark: The person who asked for that soul,
Mark: They must've meant a different human in a striped shirt!
Mark: Sorry for all the trouble! ahuhuhu
Mark: I'll make it up to you.
Mark: You can come back here anytime and for no charge at all,
Mark: I'll wrap you up and let you pl-OH.
Tyler: Play with my pet again?
Mark: Wh- I didn't!
Mark: Who's the pet?! I didn't see!!
Mark and Tyler: AHHHHHHHH
Mark: I've RUINED it!
Mark: I RUINED that.
Mark: ahuhuhuh, just k-oh.
Tyler: Oh, okay.
Mark: I thought that was gonna be a fun experience!
Tyler: ....I thought that was gonna be- yeah.
Mark: I was like "Damn it! I got missed out on
on being wrapped up in a cocoon burrito!"
Mark: I'll spahre you now.
Mark: Muffet is sparing you.
Mark: *GASP*
Tyler: Is this when yo- *GASP*
Tyler: THE KILL?!
Both: *laughing*
Mark: This is when you KILL.
Darkiplier: AH HAHA
Mark: Well maybe now I could actually check.
Mark: Muffet.
Mark: If she invites you to her parlor, excuse youself.
Mark: What are you doing?
Mark: I don- I dunno.
Mark: STRUGGLE I'm do struggle- AHHH
Tyler: NOoooo
Mark: Oh goodness!
Mark: You struggle to escape the web. Nothing happens.
Mark: It's time to go!
Mark: *giggles*
Mark: Let's see. Pay 10 gold. hUH
Mark: Refuses your mo- take my damn money!
Mark: Feeling comfortable trapped in that web?
Mark: This is, this is a bunch of crap.
Mark: ahuhu, Well I don't mind keeping you here!
Mark: If you don't mind being gobbled up!
Mark: I don't mind at all...
Tyler: ahhhhhh
Mark: Oh I, I don't mind.
Mark: Just kidding of course! Woah, are you?
Mark: hmhmhhmhmhm
Mark: Well, maybe ONE little nibble...
Mark and Tyler: All the spiders clap??
Mark: Oh boy.
Mark: HU HU hU hU
Tyler: I just DROOLED on this..
Mark: So thinking of a spider devouring you...
Mark: you alive... is just salivating at the thought.
Tyler: *awkward "that's totally NOT what I was thinking" giggles*
Mark: Nono. It's time to go.
Mark: Or is it?
Mark: *grunt???*
Mark: It's so tempting..
Tyler: It's gonna be the dot dot dots.
Mark: Look at all my- Look at all my blood in my body.
Tyler: *finds a hair*
Mark: Look at all the blood.
Mark: Great.
Tyler: Found another...
Mark: Wait now it's down to 5 gold.
Mark: Take my damn money!
Mark: TAKE MY DAMN MONEY!
Tyler: It's just the dot dot dot, it's over.
Tyler: Oh, pours you a cup of spiders...
Mark: *grunt*
Mark: That's oof, this is a bunch of crap- alright fine then.
Mark: You know what?
Mark: *flips off Muffet* hngngggnhnggng
Tyler: It would've been the spider dance, I think that's what that is- is you
Tyler: Do a spider dance.
Tyler: Is that your spider dance?
Mark: This is my spider dance.
Both: *Flip of- I mean spider dance vigorously*
Mark: Okay anyway, we're done here.
Mark: You won!
Darkiplier: She DEAD.
Tyler: Lo- Oh okay I was gonna say look at her eyes in that shot, but,
Mark: Look at her ASS.
Tyler: i SAID EYES!
Mark: Look at that spider- spider big spider BUTT.
Tyler: Look at that spider booday...
Mark: Gotta big thorax on her!
Mark: Oh gawd blimey
Mark: HAS A BIG THORAX ON HAH!
Mark: Ska-DOOSH *giggles*
Both: *laughing*
*SNIF*
Mark: *giggles*
Tyler: *giggles*
Mark: From my favorite 3D anime,
Mark: Crocodile Dun-DEE
Mark: ...and Shrek- I don't know.
Mark: I'm outta jokes.
Tyler: and Crocodile Dundee, SKADOOSH.
Mark: SkaDOOSH
Tyler: *giggles*
Mark: Kung-fu Crocodile Dundee-
*giggles*
Mark: Oh that was fun, see you again dearie.
Mark: Alrighty then. Toodles!
Tyler: Is it gonna be slow or is it gonn b-
Both: Ahhhhhhhhhh
Mark: HE UH huOOH HU
Mark: And I just lay there twitching like
Mark: She lets me go and I'm just stuck like
Mark: Help! Help! Pls!
Tyler: *zombie noises*
Darkiplier: and 7 years later your corpse is found by the next child that walks through here..
Mark: Anyway,
Tyler: At least we found out what those were for.
Mark: Yes, we finally did.
Mark: It's a poster for Mettaton's latest stage performance.
Mark: A tragic tale of two star-crossed lovers,
Mark: kept apart by the tides of fate.
Mark: Looks like it's almost time for the performance.
Tyler: Uh oh.
Mark: Uh oh- OH, should I go back and save?
Mark: Do you think there's a save point on the c-
Mark: What are the odds there's a save point on the other side of this?
Tyler: Generally pretty good because that's like a boss battle...
Tyler: buuuuuttttt....
Mark: Maybe it's thinking you'd not be stupid enough to not go back.
Mark: Imma go back.
Mark: Just in case.
Tyler: *groans*
Mark: Just a smidge in case.
Mark: Just a lil lil-
Both: WOAH
Mark: hi?
Mark: Hullo.
Mark: There you are, dearie.
Mark: You're always welcome in my parlor.
Mark: Just stay on your best behavior!
Mark: hOOAH HIUHIu
*giggles*
Mark: wiu wiu- that's the only way I know that laugh would be.
Tyler: I still, I don't think we're ever gonna laugh as hard as we did
Tyler: When we were shooting earlier today-
Mark: Oh, yeah..
Tyler: *giggles*
Mark: Oh we were shooting...uh...
Mark: I can talk about this, right? Yeah.
Tyler: It's up to you.
Mark: Nah it'll be a lil' preview, uh,
Mark: Tomorrow, I'll just say, tomorrow,
Mark: is gonna be a Yandere Simulator-themed
Mark: Uh.. a thing.
Mark: We're it's- it's so good. We bought
Mark: Those pictures you say, we have matching outfits for everybody, it's gonna be wonderful.
Mark: When we get 'em
Mark: And uh- OH That looks go good!
Tyler: Oh my,
Mark: Ethan's working on it like rn it looks really good.
Tyler: YEs! Yes.
*giggles*
Tyler: OH!
Tyler: The other screen-
Mark: OH! Great!!
Mark: Kathryn's working over on the other screen too.
Mark: She doesn't have time for our bullshit,
Mark: She's actually working hard..*giggles*
Tyler: *giggles*
Ethan: *laughs*
Mark: Ethan, that was a test. You shouldn't have looked back here.
Mark: Alright, yeah.
Mark: But uh, so they're helping out over there.
Mark: While we're doing this livestream.
Mark: And uh, but the other thing we recorded was I recorded uhh
Mark: The insult generator game,
Mark: And so, what we did was
Tyler: Oh my god...
Mark: we basically made a little sketch were
Tyler: *laughing*
Mark: sat down across from a table
Mark: and we did like a roast of eachother. *giggles*
Tyler: *laughs*
Mark: And it got SO REAL!
Ethan: OHH
Tyler: *giggles*
Mark: *dying* and it got so real...
Tyler: *laughing* ...so real.
Mark: SO REAL!
Mark: EXCEPT FOR YOURS, NOT REAL..
Tyler: *laughing*
Tyler: MINE WERE JUST FUNNY AS HELL.
Mark: *laughing*
Mark: Suuuuurrrrreeeee.....
Tyler: The way I was saying-
Mark: But oh man, it was just hilarious.
Tyler: But I remember back in the day *laughs*
Mark: *laughs* Back in the day...
Both: *laughing*
Mark: Oh jeez...
Mark: See, there wasn't a save point.
Mark: It's a good idea we went back.
Tyler: Yes.
Mark: OH?
Mark: That humnnn...
Mark: Is that me? Is that Mettaton?
Tyler: Is it Mettaton?
Mark: *scoffs?*
Tyler: YEP
Mark: Could it be?
Mark: Th-
Tyler: woAH..
Mark: My one true love??
*fairytale-esque music starts playing*
Mark: Oh jesus-
Tyler: Oh no-
Mark: OH. OHH.
Tyler: *laughing*
Mark: Hi, Metty.
Mark: That does seem like something I would do, admittedly.
Mark: I've worn a fair number of dresses *giggles*
Tyler: We just wore them *laughs*
Mark: Some very nice Japanese schoolgirl outfits.
Tyler: Yes.
Mark: God I keep getting distracted now cuz I'm watchin
Mark: OH!
Mark: OH MY LO-OVE
Mark: PLEASE RUN A- I have no idea if this is sang-
Mark: PLEASE RUN AWAYY
Mark: MONSTER KIIIIIIIIIIIIIIIINNGG
Mark: FORBIDS YOUR STAY-AY-AYYYYYYY
Mark: HUMANS /MU/ST....
Mark: LIVE FAR APART...
Mark: EVEN IIIFFF...
Both: IT BREAKS MY HEART :'(
Mark: THEY'LL PUT YOUUU
Mark: IN THE DUNGEON...
Mark: IT'LL SU-*laughs*
Tyler: *laughs*
Mark: AND THEN YOU'LL DIE A LOHAHAHT
Mark: Sounds like me, exactly.
Mark: REALLY SAAAD
Darkiplier: YOU'RE GONNA DIEE!
Mark: CRY CRY CRY
Mark: SO SAD IT'S HAPPENING..
Mark: I didn't quite hear. the tone there. so I wasn't
Mark: sure. If it got that right. But I think I nailed that.
Tyler: I think you did pretty good.
Tyler: I knew you were gonna do that...
Tyler: I KNEW YOU WERE GONNA DO THAT!
Mark: *laughing*
Tyler: Ah, just don't hurt my hand.
Mark: There we go, alright.
Mark: Finally completed the circle.
Mark: So sad.
Mark: So sad that you're going to the dungeon.
Mark: Oh well- Well, toodles!
Mark: AHhh
Mark: Oh this doesn't look like the dungeon
Mark: It looks like everything else we were doing.
Mark: OH no- wha?
Tyler: Oh that's his rocket- It looks really weird with the dress there.
Mark: Oh it's PUBES are fluttering in the wind. (um)
Mark: Like I died my hair pink
Mark: And ??? got pink pubes.
Tyler: *dying*
Mark: hehe, anyway,
Tyler: Oh god...
Mark: Let's see. Oh no!
Mark: Whatever shall I do?
Mark: My love has been cast away into the dungeon.
Mark: A dungeon with a puzzle so dastardly,
Mark: My paramour will surely perish.
Mark: Oh... *GASP*
Tyler: Oh it's the-
Tyler: Oh the colored tile thing.
Mark: Oh the horrible colored tile maze!
Mark: Each colored tile has its own sadistic function.
Mark: For example, *GASP*
Mark: For example, a green tile sounds a noise
Mark: And the- okay I think we actually have to remember this.
Tyler: Yes. Green is monster.
Mark: Monster..
Mark: Red tiles will...
Tyler: Red is-
*robot noises*
Mark: Uhh...UGH
Mark: *cough*
Tyler: Oh no.
Mark: That's right you remember all th- AWWWWWWW
Tyler: AWWWWWWWWWW
Tyler: I believe yellow electrocutes you.
Mark: WWWWWWWW
Mark: But
Tyler: Blue is swim.
Mark: If yellow is next to water er-
Mark: If blue is next to yellow,
Both: It'll electrocute you.
Tyler: Yeah.
Mark: Red is okay.
Mark: ..as far as I remember.
Tyler: No, red you can't pass through.
Mark: So green means monster, water is okay,
Mark: But, so if we went,
Tyler: PINK
Mark: Pink is okay.
Tyler: Yeah.
Mark: OH and you better hurry!
Mark: Because if you don't get through in 30 seconds,
Mark: Okay we really have to look at this. So,
Mark: Green, blue, green, yellow, pink, blue, pink
Mark: I think that- no.
Mark: What's purple?
Tyler: You can't go through yellow.
Mark: Somethin' about purple. Sharks don't like...
Mark: Sharks don't like it when you're...
Mark: Sharks don't like it when your a thing wh
Mark: When you smell like a thing- so you can't go through the water
Tyler: Without- orange is the smelly tile.
Mark: Something like that.
Mark: Okay.
Mark: UH oh.
Darkiplier: You'll be incinerated by these jets of fire!
Darkiplier: HA HA HA HA HAHAHAHAH
Mark: My poor love,
Mark: I'm filled with so much grief,
Mark: I can't stop laughing!
Mark: Good luck darling! Alright I think I know what I need to do.
Tyler: You can't go...
Mark: Okay.
Mark: Okay I think I need to go North.
*rejected*
Mark: wow
Mark: Oh, gotcha.
Tyler: That was electrocute. Down-
Mark: Right. Okay that's right!
Mark: Purple makes you move forward and-
Mark: then- Oh that's electricity
Mark: So we gotta move forward
Tyler: You gotta go through purple.
Mark: Yeah and then we can go through
Mark: this purple.
Tyler: UP
Mark: Swing through here,
Tyler: Down.
Mark: We caaaaaaan't
Tyler: Nope we gotta go down.
Mark: Down, there's no- yeah.
Tyler: Nope, down.
Mark: Down-
Tyler: Down, around.
Mark: This way.
Mark: Nope that would electrocute you.
Tyler: Nope.
Mark: So straight down here,
Tyler: Yup.
Mark: Through- Oh.
Mark: Oh I'm so sorry! Looks like you're out of time.
Mark: HOOAHHHH
Mark: Here come the flames, darling!
Mark: Goooooewwww
Mark: They're closing in!
Mark: Eghhh
Mark: Getting closer! Oh my!
Mark: Any minute now.
* (MARK COUGH)
Tyler: Watch out! I'll save you!
Mark: *giggles*
Mark: *laughs*
Tyler: I'm hacking into the firewall right now!
Mark: Ohhh.
Mark: Cool thanks!
(Did neither of them get the joke....?)
Mark: Oh no. How could this happen?
Mark: Foiled again by the brilliant Dr. Alphys- Wait a minute...
Mark: Wait a minute.
Mark: Somethin' ain't right here.
Mark: Something ain't right at all.
Tyler: Alphys programmed that robot.
Mark: Alphys- Alphys designed this whole thing.
Mark: To make it seem like Alphys is a hero.
Tyler: Yes.
Tyler: But, we discussed this, I believe, last time.
Mark: Did we?
Tyler: I think so.
Mark: Hmmm....
Mark: I suddenly don't trust Alphys and I LOVE METTATON.
Mark: Cuz he's- he's me.
Mark: Wh- What was that???
Tyler: Uhhh can we go back?
Mark: No. Wh-?
Tyler: That's right!
Mark: I didn't press a button that was just like "bleh".
Tyler: Oh.
Tyler: Come on Mettaton, give up already!
Tyler: You'll never be able to defeat us.
Tyler: Not as long as we work together.
Mark: *exhale*
Tyler: Your puzzle's over.
Tyler: Now go home and leave us alone!
Mark: Puzzle?
Mark: Over?
Mark: Alphys, darling. What are you talking about?
Mark: Did you forget what the green tiles do?
Mark: They make a sound,
Mark: then you have to fight a monster!
Mark: Well darling, that monster-
Darkiplier: IS ME.
Mark: Uh oh!
Mark: Fu-
Tyler: Oh, this is the quiz thing again.
Mark: Is it? Are you sure about that?
Tyler: I think so.
Mark: Yell. AHHH! That's what I always do.
Markiton: This is it darling, say goodbye.
Mark: Hello?
Markiton: Is that your phone? You'd better answer it now!
Mark: That's you. That's Alphys.
Typhys: Hn-Hey!
Typhys: This seems bad, but don't worry!
Typhys: There's one last thing I installed on your phone!
Typhys: You see that yellow button?
Mark: Yah
Typhys: Go to this phone's "ACT"
Typhys: menu and press it.
Mark: Okayyyyy?
Mark: My PHONE'S act menu?
Mark: My-
Tyler: Item?
Mark: Wha?
Mark: I don- I don't have a phone's act menu!
Tyler: Hit act.
Tyler: Mettaton.
Mark: Oh, okay.
Mark: You press the yellow button. Your phone is resonating
Mark: with Mettaton's presence.
Markiton: This is it darling. Say goodbye.
Mark: uh
Mark: Uh oh woah hey woah hey woah
Mark: Uh...
Markiphys: Now press "Z"!!!
Tyler: AH
Mark: OOH
Markiton: OOOOOOOH!
Markiton: oooOOOOOOOOoooh!
Markiton: You've defeated me!
Markiton: How can this be? You were stronger than I thought. ECT.
Markiton: Whatever. *just mark* Ohhohohohoho, okay.
Mark: Oh..
Mark: Ring.
Typhys: Looks like you beat him!
Mark: Uh uh.
Typhys: You did a really great job out there.
Mark: *groaning?*
Tyler: All thanks to you or dot dot dot?
Typhys: Um, hey, this might sound strange but-
Typhys: Can I tell you somethin'?
Typhys: Before I met you, I didn't really...
Typhys: I didn't really like myself very much.
Typhys: For a long time, I felt like a total screwup.
Typhys: Like I couldn't do anything without
Typhys: Without ending- letting everyone down.
Typhys: b-b-b-but!
Typhys: Guiding you has made me feel
Typhys: A lot better about myself.
Typhys: So thanks for letting me help you.
Typhys: Uh, anyway,
Typhys: We're almost to the CORE.
Typhys: It's just past MTT Resort.
Typhys: Come on! Let's finish this!
Mark: Okay so what's interesting here is obviously,
Mark: Alphys is constructing this scenario in order to...
Mark: Make you feel good about being friends with her?
Mark: And I can see that as manipulative,
Mark: it's definitely manipulative, 100%, right?
Tyler: Yeah.
Mark: But at the same time, it is helping
Mark: Her, her, her...her.
Tyler: Her.
Mark: It's helping her out with her own
sense of self worth. As far as we know,
Mark: this could all be a clever rouse...
Mark: So, hmmm...*SNIF*
Mark: Who knows? I'm waiting for more information at this point, bu- *GASP*
Mark: The muscular bongos!
Mark: Oh, hey.
Mark: Like, we're,
Mark: Talkin'- Taking a rain check on that "killing you" thing...
Mark: Like, don't tell Undyne about this, okay?
Mark: He seems happy.
Mark: Aww
Tyler: Aww, what happens if we go left?
Mark: Something else is gonna pat like a muscular bongo if you know what I'm sayin'...
Tyler: Ayyyyyyy
*Manly laughter*
Mark: Hey! It's you again.
Mark: Business is excellent here!
Mark: These two fellas bought all my ice cream.
Mark: I'm actually sold out of everything!
Mark: Sorry.
Mark: Wait! I've still got something for you!
Mark: A big smile, how about that?
Mark: Hey, thanks man. I also got somethin' for you.
Mark: *flips him off* HOH, You better give me somethin!
Mark: *finger guns* HUH
Mark: Pshew Phshew
Tyler: SKADOOSH
*giggles*
Mark: Skadoosh, buddy.
Mark: Skadoosh. Skadoosh to you, Skadoosh to them.
Mark: Skadoosh them like muscular bongos.
Tyler: hullo?
Mark: Ohhhh, this is the stage,,,,,
Mark: I guess we can go back and save, maybe??
Tyler: Ehhh, let's do that.
Mark: Eh, it's not too far anyway. We might as well do that.
Mark: I bet there's gonna be
Mark: A sa- WOAH
Tyler: ...WOAH
Mark: Hi?
Mark: mm you do this one.
Tyler: Mettaton looked really
Tyler: REALLY cool in that dress.
Tyler: It sorta makes me feel like I could wear one, too.
Mark: You do you, man!
Mark: Don't let anybody tell you how to live your life.
Mark: You are,
Mark: Beautiful.
Mark: *fart noises*
Tyler: Oh no spider weyb
Tyler: ooAHH!
Tyler: OOOOH
Mark: pfft pfft
Mark: You having fun there?
Tyler: Yis.
Mark: Alright, that's what's important.
Tyler: *giggles*
Mark: Alright, so I have no idea what's next...
Mark: but I have a funny feeling,
Tyler: It's the big- yeah.
Mark: Well I have a funny feeli-